[Music]
as a developer i often find myself
needing to store data in a relational
database
i'd really like to let someone else
worry about the management of the
database architecture and i'd like it to
scale easily without worsening
performance i know cloud spanner is a
great solution for scalability but i
don't have a lot of data and my
application generates a fairly low
amount of requests at the moment i've
heard that spanner is only for really
large use cases like storing youtube
data
i'm concerned that spanner may be too
much for my workload
if this sounds like you the google cloud
spanner team is happy to introduce
granular instant sizing
now you can use spanner from a much
smaller starting point and at a lower
cost
cloud spanner is a great choice for any
application that requires availability
and strong consistency without losing
out on performance as a managed cloud
native database spanner provides high
availability by managing additional
copies of your data called replicas
replicas ensure data is persisted and
requests will continue to work
seamlessly without downtime and without
the need for you to manage complicated
architectures
as a horizontally scaling relational
database
spanner is able to guarantee strong
consistency of your data by utilizing
acid transactions and leveraging a
distributed clock called true time to
guarantee ordering of commits even
across geographic locations
this consistency is critical to prevent
unexpected data discrepancies
as one example imagine two players of a
game making a trade
consistency is needed to guarantee the
first player gets the money and the
second gets the item
spanner also allows you to easily scale
up as your workload grows without
requiring you to manage complex sharding
one way spanner is able to support the
scalability is by separating compute and
storage
when you create a spanner instance up
until now you specify the instance size
in terms of nodes
nodes determine how much compute and
storage you have access to
it does not impact the availability
guarantees a spanner or the number of
replicas your instance has
a single node provides enough compute
capacity for up to 10 000 reads per
second or up to 2000 writes per second
you also get storage capacity for 4
terabytes of data
this compute and storage capacity might
be too much for many applications and
this over-provisioning may have caused
application teams to hesitate to choose
spanner despite the great benefits of
the database solution
with the release of granular instance
sizing it is now easier than ever and
more cost efficient to start using
spanner
granular instant sizing introduces a new
unit called processing units
1000 processing units is the equivalent
of a single node
when you create a new instance you can
either specify the size as a number of
nodes or a number of processing units
you can size your instance as low as 100
processing units or 1 10 the storage and
compute capacity of a single node at one
tenth the cost
granular instance sizing lets you get
started with spanner starting at sixty
five dollars a month
for example now your team can get
started with test and dev instances that
don't need the full compute capacity a
single node provides
you can size the instances for the
amount of compute capacity you need
if your capacity needs start to grow
spanner makes it easy to scale up
without downtime to your users
scaling up can be done incrementally to
avoid over provisioning your spanner
resources
granular instant sizing allows your team
to get the incredible features of
spanner including strong consistency
high availability and scalability
without overpaying for unused resources
so go ahead and provision your spanner
instance with granular instant sizing
[Music]
you